A couple of years ago,
I went to a totally normal party.
It was put on by the well-muscled
brain explorer, Bryan Johnson.
He held the event at this
house in Venice, California.
Billionaire Patrick Collison
was there and so was his smile.
The guests all got together,
donned Bluetooth headphones
and listened to music written
by an AI and performed
by "American Idol"
contestant Taryn Southern.
Oh, and you can also take a whiff
of an extinct Hawaiian
plant because some people
who play with DNA had found a way
to bring its smell back to life.
The folks who did the DNA manipulation
work at Ginkgo Bioworks.
The company is perhaps the world leader
in the field of synthetic biology.
Earlier this year, Ginkgo
raised a staggering $2.5 billion
on its way to being valued at 15 billion.
To find out what $2.5
billion buys you these days,
I went to Ginkgo's headquarters
in Boston, Massachusetts
for it is here
or make that here
that the company is building
out a DNA superhighway.
Ginkgo was founded back in
2009 by several big brains
from MIT, including its CEO Jason Kelly.
The founders wanted to develop ways
to treat DNA more or
less like software code.
You find an organism with
an interesting property,
snip out the DNA behind that property
and then shove the DNA
fragment into something else.
The big promise behind synthetic
biology is that we'll find
a new means to harness nature
and bend it to our will.
We'll be able to manufacture
things like chemicals
and fuels and even physical
objects in ultra efficient ways.
To be clear, we're also talking
about eventually getting
into Jurassic Park mad
scientist-style stuff
and this grand experiment could end up
with you being a reptile's breakfast.
The core idea behind the company
was inside of every cell,
every bacteria, plant,
animal on planet earth
is digital code in the form of DNA.
So it's A, T, Cs and Gs, not
zeroes and ones like you'd see
in a computer, but you can read that code
with DNA sequencing and
importantly, you can write that code
with DNA printing.
And this is for a bio nerd
like me, this is magic.
You literally go on a
computer, you type ATCGGGG,
you hit print and out of
machines in this facility
or the ones next door comes a piece of DNA
that's exactly what you ordered.
And then you can put that into a cell.
And our idea was if you can
read and write code and you have
a machine that'll run it, which
is how we thought of a cell,
you're programming just
like you program a computer.
And so Ginkgo's business is
basically programmer tools
so that other folks can
develop new programs for cells.
This core synthetic biology principle
of treating DNA like
code is simple in theory.
In most cases, scientists
will grab the DNA they want
and insert it into something
like a bacteria or yeast.
Then they create lots of
copies of the organisms
in much the same way as we make beer.
They feed the organisms
sugar and nutrients
and grow them in a vat.
So I'll give you an example.
There was a flower that went extinct
in I think it was the
early 1900s in Hawaii,
but before it went extinct,
it had gotten collected
by scientists and then stored
and it's actually it was at
the Harvard Botanical Museum.
And so we collected some of that sample,
brought it back here to Gingko,
put it through our DNA sequencer.
So we read the DNA code
of that extinct flower.
We found the part of the DNA
that encoded for the scent.
So we'd take those 6,000 letters of DNA
and move them into a
bacterial genome like E. coli.
So how do you do that?
Well, you have a special enzyme
that basically can find
a location on the genome
that looks for ATGGs, whatever one is
on the specific code it has and it cuts.
And then it opens and then
you add in those 6,000 letters
from the extinct flower genome.
How did you get them?
Well, you read them, you
had them on the computer,
you put them in ATCG, hit print
and you printed a piece of synthetic DNA.
So now you add that in to where you cut
and then you patch it up a
little bit, grow the cell.
Instead of just doing the normal
swim around bacteria thing,
it also now makes this fragrance.
And so we actually resurrected the scent
of this extinct flower as
a project that ended up
it's actually showing
at a few art museums.
To kind of bring it back.
To see some of this process in action,
I went to visit Sara in
one of Ginkgo's labs.
Okay, so somebody, you've made a microbe,
you've engineered it with
a specific bit of DNA
to give it a quality
that you are looking for
and then you guys are both making those
and checking that
they're coming out right.
We're testing a lot of
different engineered strains
to help us build our
code base to understand
which of those pieces of DNA are able
to achieve the desired outcome.
Okay, and so you've got
these cells over here.
Some of them have stuff on them, the white
and some of them don't.
So I assume the ones with the
white is ones that have worked
and that's what you're looking for.
Yeah, so each of those individual segments
is a particular engineered
strain that we are trying
to isolate in order to
then test downstream.
The segments that have the
individual white circles
which we call colonies have
successfully taken up that DNA.
So this would be the beginning stage
of you'd get what you want
and then you can grow it
in bigger quantities.
You can study it, yeah.
So this is the very start
of that kind of pipeline.
What Gingko really wants
to do is automate all
of this and make meddling
with DNA fast and cheap.
To do that, you need a factory.
This is perhaps the most
modern DNA assembly line
on the planet.
Molecules go in at one
end of the conveyor belt
and robots take care of
all the processes needed
to refine them into something useful.
So this is a magnetic propulsion system
that has individual carts.
And the robots
or the humans will load
samples onto these carts
and then the system will know
which destination they need to take them.
So a human comes here and puts a sample,
feeds it into the system.
Exactly, there you go.
And now you can press
the button over here.
And then off it goes.
And the green robot is gonna grab them.
Now, you can see the
green robots pick it up
and will place it on the
second station there.
And this is when the yellow
robot will come into play.
Your little yellow robot will
remove some of the samples,
add controls in their place.
The tube rack then goes to
a next oscillating station,
which is a centrifuge work cell here.
Spin it around, so essentially
to try to remove bubbles
or anything that might have formed
during shipping of the samples.
Okay, I think our sample's off again.
So now we're sealing the plates
and it can go over the
rest of the process.
It all ends
with an incredibly
sophisticated trash can.
These specialized trash work cells
have these specialized
carts that weigh the amount
of trash that there is
in each of these bags
to know when they are full.
And finally, the robots can
actually place the trash
at random positions around the bag
to make sure they're
not always stacking up
in the center making very large towers
that can eventually break the system.
And does a human have to
take this out at the end?
This is the last step
where the human is still in the loop.
Step forward, one helpful TV host.
I remember around 2008, it
was getting easier a bit
to manipulate DNA and we could
see where things were going,
but people were already saying
in a few years we're gonna be
you will program a cell to make a chair
and we won't have chair factories anymore,
we'll just grow them.
And so how much of that
vision do you still believe in
and how close are we to this idea
that we're gonna just be making
fantastic new things out of biology?
I think it's all coming, yeah.
You do?
Yeah, the reason is I can't
emphasize this enough,
people take biology massively for granted.
Every other engineering
field was designed by humans
from the bottom up.
We know every little
bolt in that Ford car,
every little gate in that
semiconductor chip from Intel.
Well, biology is ridiculously advanced
and we're just entering
the era of being able
to program it to do new things.
We know it's capable of big things.
The only limit is human
understanding to be able
to program it, but we know if we learn,
it can do this stuff because
it's already doing it.
It's making our food,
it's cleaning our water,
it's making the air.
We're made out of it.
And the one magical feature
of it and it is a miracle
is it's programmable because
inside of it is digital code
that we can as humans read and write.
Ginkgo does go after some weird stuff.
This dog, for example used
to be a tea cup poodle
just last week.
And clearly, people here really do dream
of doing things like
resurrecting the dinosaurs.
But as with any new technology,
I wanted to know how synthetic
biology would benefit me,
like right now.
And so I took what we'll call
the blood elevator express
a couple floors down to another
startup, Motif Foodworks.
Motif is a research and
development company for food
that uses synthetic biology
to make food taste better.
Today, I'm here to eat a burger,
only no cow was involved.
Motif teamed with Ginkgo
to take the DNA code
for hemoglobin, plop it into a yeast
and then grow what amounts
to a vat of faux blood.
This fellow here is adding
the blood to some soy,
throwing in some seasonings.
And then, voila.
Thank you so much.
Well, should we try it
while it's still hot?
Absolutely, that's the best way.
Okay.
It's good.
It's burgery, for sure and
it has that on the char
and all that.
The char, the bite quality is much better.
I would say that old
generations of plant-based meat,
the first bite, you might
get this crust on the outside
like you see here,
but the second bite would be more mushy.
The inside would not have texture.
So look at all the effort.
I mean, that pretty much looks like
what you might see in a burger.
You notice all the pieces,
the way it crumbles.
The other thing I noticed is
there's definitely that
umami kind of note on there.
Well, our ingredient we call
hemami and it's essentially
the molecule in the muscle
of a cow that makes beef red,
it makes it give you that
beautiful serumy, bloody flavor.
It catalyzes a whole bunch
of the chemistry in there.
And that is an amazing piece of technology
that Ginkgo Bioworks created for us.
Ginkggo was able to look at
300 different muscle proteins
from different species, mini sperm whales,
one that comes to mind,
tuna, pork, chicken, a whole
series of different birds.
And they were already sequenced,
so it wasn't like we
took any animal material.
When they did the sequences, it was for--
Specific muscle protein,
a class called myoglobins.
Ginkgo got us the ability to look
at all the different properties,
stability, taste, flavor, color.
And then once we honed
in on the ones we wanted,
we asked them to optimize the yeast,
to turn that into a mini
factory so that we can make it
and so we can have the great taste of beef
without using any animals.
To put a fine symbolic point
on how all of this stuff gets
made, I felt it essential
to go to a nearby brewery with Jason.
I thought being in a brewery was--
Yeah, ideal, right?
They use yeast, but no
commercial beer today is made
with engineered cells.
Have you ever had a non-alcoholic
beer, it tastes like shit?
Well, that's because it's
getting rid of the alcohol,
you're pulling off all
the flavor components.
And so could you make a yeast
that doesn't produce much alcohol
that gives you all the taste?
So you end up with an alcohol-free beer
that actually tastes good.
Brewing is an industry that
has biology so intrinsic to it
that's actually an
opportunity to figure that out
and do it correctly.
We've worked on the breweries.
I think it's gonna come
around pretty soon actually.
Thank you.
Oh, look at that.
Thanks, cheers, man, to yeast.
Yeah, to yeast.
Oh, that's good.
I wanted to go back just a little bit.
Where'd you grow up?
I grew up in Florida.
Yeah, yeah, South Florida.
And what was your family a family of?
We weren't a family of PhD,
I was the first person to get a PhD.
But were you even good in
high school and everything,
was science your thing?
Yeah, honestly I think what
it was I was 12, 13 years old
when Jurassic Park came out.
And I was a big sci-fi
nerd, I was reading books.
I read all those Crichton
books, I love that stuff.
And I think I fell in love with it then.
What kid wouldn't dream of playing God?
To that end, I wanted to know
when we'd get past perfumes
and fast food blood and
get to the good stuff,
the freaky stuff.
Well, I was talking with the
guys that help make the show.
This is one of the lingering questions
that we still weren't sure about.
I can get the enzymes,
they'd cut and paste DNA.
I can get it to make the myoglobin,
but then why can't you grow an arm
is what we kept talking about in the car.
It's like why can't you put
in the code for the arm then?
If you can put in the
code for the protein,
why can't you do the whole thing?
It's a great question and this is like me
when I got to MIT.
I'm like, I thought I would
be making arms or something.
The short answer is, we don't understand
the specific sequence of
DNA, how it affects the cell.
It's just because we didn't design cells
and they're complicated.
And so if up put in some
new DNA that was like,
I think this DNA will make
an arm, it just wouldn't.
But it might make some
other deranged thing.
But it's like salamanders.
The frickin salamander
grows arms but humans don't.
And so it's just a programming problem
between here and there,
but we know the substrate
is capable of it.
Obviously, everyone thinks
about climate change
all the time.
And I don't wanna give people false hope
on any of this stuff, but
something that's just gobble it.
Why can't we just gobble
carbon and shit out happiness
on the other side?
Where is that?
I'll give you a real one,
I'll give you a real project.
So the project we're doing,
we have $100 million joint
venture with Bayer CropScience.
You know synthetic nitrogen fertilizer?
Okay, the way you make it,
you basically pull nitrogen
out of the air.
You're basically gonna take that nitrogen,
you're gonna combine it with
hydrogen to make ammonia,
which is fertilizer.
Where do you get the hydrogen?
Oh, burning natural gas.
Okay, so you burn natural gas.
I think it's like 4% global
greenhouse gas is going
to frickin fertilizer,
but hey, we get to eat.
We need fertilizer.
Okay, well, there are
certain crops like soybeans
that don't need much fertilizer, why?
They have microbes in their roots,
they're literally pulling
nitrogen out of the air--
Nature doing all the work.
It's like you plant a legume
and it refertilizes the soil.
So we can go find the code
that produces fertilizer
for crops in soybeans,
we can take microbes
that are friendly with corn,
install that code and then
a business that Bayer already
has you do a seed treatment.
You basically coat the
seed in those bacteria
and when you plant it,
they grow along with it
and they produce fertilizer for the crop.
That's the project.
So that's one where if
you actually succeeded,
not only is it a $70 billion market,
it's a 4% global greenhouse gas reduction.
No, that's cool.
But no, nothing's just out there
gobbling CO2 out of the air yet.
Well, trees.
Yeah.
That's an amazing, amazing machine.
And it is like when you fly in an airplane
and look out the window, what do you see?
Trees, that is real scale.
None of this crap like our
auto plants and chip fabs,
it's a joke.
The only real scale on the planet
that's actually making
anything is biology.
The only thing we're good at making is CO2
and fucking things up.
To Jason's point, humans
do have a tendency
to run amok when given new toys.
And this could all go
bad, Jurassic Park bad.
That said, synthetic biology
is the area of technology
that excites me the most.
The stuff bubbling away
in these jars and flowing
through these tubes
represents our best shot
at fixing many of the messes we've made
and at doing so many other
things better in the future.
It's certainly not communing with nature
in any traditional sense, but it's an area
where humans can meld
science and creativity
in previously unimaginable ways.
In DNA, there is hope.